i'm joined now by ocean gate
expedition's rory golden who's been on
four titanic expeditions and three dives
of the wreck including uh one this year
thanks so much for for joining us rory
and congrats on capturing these these
amazing new images
oh delicious to be here and tell the
story wilfred thank you for having me on
and and so you're obviously passionate
about titanic having gone down three
times talk talk us through the process
of capturing these images and why you're
so excited by these these latest ones
well it ties in as you say with ocean
gate expeditions uh stockton rush the
founder of the company created a new
five-person submersible after carbon
fiber this is groundbreaking technology
because
no submersible has has been able to go
to this jet with five people on board my
previous dies were in the russian mere
submersibles that people saw on the
james cameron movie
so this new technology combined with
this new imaging camera systems
is making uh new discoveries in as much
as clarity and
new parts of the wreck that we haven't
seen before for example the portside
anchor
has shown up the manufacturer's name of
hindley and company uh in the uk
i have never seen this image before and
ph nargerly who is also one of the
expedition experts has made 37 dives to
titanic he never saw this this
detail before so the ak imaging is
giving us incredible clarity and far
more detail and this combined with the
scientists that are on board the ocean
gate expeditions because these are
scientific expeditions marine biologists
archaeologists
uh people with specialities in various
parts of the deep ocean they've been
taking water samples and they've been
monitoring the decay of the wreck the
rusticles the these things you see there
dripping down from the side of the
pieces of the machinery on the ship
all this has got to give us far more
information that we had up to now many
expeditions before have created and
gathered a lot of information and these
are starting points for us to go forward
with what are there things that we've
never found the answer to that that we
could now discover are there
details of why the ship went down that
could come to light that haven't
previously
no all those facts were about
established uh friends there's nothing
really new to be found out about the
ship sinking in the breakup there are
still parts of the ship that haven't
been seen such as the areas where the
ship struck the iceberg because that's
buried in mud
the the bow section is the most
recognizable feature it looks like the
ship was at the forward end
that plowed into the ocean seabed and
and scurried forward a coup a couple of
hundred meters and came to a rest
very that bow section there
um
it practically touches the sea bed but
after only a few meters and was 60 feet
high to the bottom that's how much is
buried
but um
a lot of the wreckage like there the the
engines um are in the
stern section which is completely
smashed up and quite unrecognizable the
bow section as i say people always
associate
mostly with the titanic and even there
we have seen
rapid areas of decay such as the main
mass collapse completely
the officers quarters captain smith's
cabin completely collapsed so the ship
is disintegrating and part of these
expeditions is to try to monitor the
rate of decay using this new scientific
uh equipment that we now have and and
can this equipment now will you expect
it to be used in other sorts of dives if
you've got others on on your list uh
that
that could now discover and take
pictures of things that we haven't seen
before
well that's quite possible but ocean
gates plans for the next three or four
years is to continue to go back and make
annual repeat drives to the titanic this
has never been done before in a
scientific way there have been
explorations uh
i think the last one was 2010 when there
was a big woods hole expedition to
survey the wreck and did a great mapping
job of the whole site now we're in a
different era of technology a different
era of exploration and it's really
exciting stuff the oceans
are what we depend on for our lives as a
planet and
the deep oceans are still the most
inaccessible part of the earth that
we've go to it's a cliche i've said it
many times more people have been to
outer space now than those people who
have been to the depths of the ocean
where the titanic is no that's an
amazing amazing statistic rory as as we
go
only because you mentioned the film
there the the james cameron movie i just
wanted to ask quickly for someone that's
such an expert on titanic as you well
you've already answered my question i
was going to say do you do you hate the
movie or love the movie
no i uh the movie the movie was done
incredibly well james cameron went
through an awful lot of detail to get
the uh the features of the ship correct
the story it's a love story and it
introduced a whole generation of people
to the whole story of titanic so it was
a catalyst for many people and it's a
fine movie and won't you just see it in
the context of that and that's where i
rest on it i enjoyed the movie i think
it was done incredibly well and all give
credit to james cameron for opening up
the doors to people and introducing
titanic to generations because the
titanic story continues it appeals to
children all across the world adults all
across the world it's a global name and
and with your new kit maybe you'll find
that lost necklace i know i'm just
joking it's not real don't worry about
it thanks so much rory much appreciated